be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so as we pick up with this week's comic
book concepts we continue the Xavier
protocols by focusing on Nightcrawler
Sabretooth mystique Sunfire Thunderbird
and Dazzler so for those of you who are
new to my channel following the
onslaught saga which saw Charles Xavier
is frustration with humanity and
Magneto's hatred of humanity merging
into a singular entity and laying waste
to the world's heroes Xavier had
initiated a set of protocols designed
for the purpose of defeating and if
necessary killing various mutants who
would use their powers for the purpose
of world domination and so beginning
with Nightcrawler as a mutant with the
power to teleport himself and others
across limited spaces Kurt Wagner is a
tricky foe to catch requiring virtually
no concentration during the
teleportation process Nightcrawler jumps
through the brimstone dimension of the
Nayef m coming out at a predetermined
location at the same time and because of
his training by Xavier Nightcrawler
presents a formidable threat only to his
ability to teleport parts of his foes
away and capacitating or killing them in
the process
in addition to this Kurt's time as part
of the x-men Excalibur and various other
groups has allowed him to train in a
variety of fighting styles meaning that
if his powers were deactivated he still
presents himself as a dangerous foe more
than capable of handling his own that
said Nightcrawler is not without
weaknesses considered to be predictable
by those who have fought him on a
regular basis Nightcrawler is also a
Catholic possessing a strong moral
compass with refused to kill except for
the dyrus of circumstances in addition
to this because Nightcrawler shares the
blood of the Naya femme a race of demons
living within the brimstone dimension
itself the blood of the angelic Seraphim
is capable of damaging Nightcrawler with
prolonged exposure leading to his death
however barring intervention from
heavenly bodies the best means of
defeating and killing Nightcrawler
comes in the form of blink and
Sabretooth with Nightcrawler being
susceptible to the same forms of illness
and injury as a normal human blinks
powers of teleportation would allow her
to predict nightcrawlers movements and
teleport him to Sabretooth location who
in turn would easily overpower and kill
Kurt
moving on to Sabretooth while he does
have a healing factor that allows him to
recover from virtually any and all
damage including the loss of limbs as
well as making him immune to poisons
most drugs toxins and diseases
Sabretooth true power lies in his
ferocity and
enhanced senses possessing the ability
to see and complete darkness here are
all ranges of sound frequencies and
track the scent of his target regardless
of degradation sabertooth presents a
formidable threat to almost any opponent
in addition to this Sabretooth himself
does not have any true weakness to speak
of owing to the fact that his healing
factor heightened senses and ferocity
all come together to form a wildly
durable killing machine with a desire to
inflict chaos and pain that said the
best means of defeating and killing
Sabretooth comes in the form of
Wolverine due to his equal level of
ferocity as well as level of fighting
that can easily counter Sabretooth lack
of intelligence and abilities
transitioning to mystique as a mutant
with the base power of metamorphosis
mystique presents herself as a wildly
difficult foe to catch owing to the idea
that if she were to escape into a crowd
with the exception of high-level
telepaths and those with an acute sense
of smell she would be nigh uncatchable
however after dying and being
resurrected by the hand the clandestine
ninja clans ties to missus ISM allow for
an expansion of Mystique's abilities
making her capable of tricking
Wolverines sense of smell as well as
camouflage to her surroundings to the
point of near invisibility as well as
take on the form of metallic materials a
feat previously unavailable in addition
to this Mystique's longevity may surpass
even wolverine himself making her one of
the oldest mutants on the planet with
the exception of saline and apocalypse
as such her experience in avoiding
detection through espionage and
subterfuge mastery over both extinct and
existing forms of language as well as
mastery in various forms of martial arts
and weapons training make her extremely
dangerous if her goal is to intend harm
on others however mystique is not
without her own weaknesses while she is
able to avoid Wolverine sense of smell
she is still detectable by high-level
telepaths in addition to this mystique
cannot take on the form of objects with
lesser or greater mass than herself
meaning she could not transform into a
child or a giant as a result the best
person suited to defeat and kill
mystique comes in the form of Jean Grey
whose telepathy would allow her to enter
the mind of mystique and shut down
access to her powers after which she
could be killed by any number of
conventional meetings
moving on to Sunfire as a mutant with
power similar to that of Johnny Storm
Shiro Yoshida is able to use his powers
for a multitude of effects including
flight
glass plasma shields oxygen generation
and emitting temperatures of up to 1
million degrees Fahrenheit
all of which stems from his body's
natural ability to absorb solar
radiation through the air in addition to
this because of his time as part of the
Yoshida clan his family's long-running
legacy of martial arts mastery was
passed down making him adept in
hand-to-hand combat using karate judo
kendo Aikido and Kimpo as a result
because the radiation of the Sun
immerses the Earth's atmosphere mutants
like storm would have no effect if she
were to block out the Sun invoke rain or
initiate a blizzard and Sun fire solar
emanation would melt the adamantium from
Wolverines claws and incinerate his body
due to adamantium melting point of 74
hundred degrees Fahrenheit conversely a
Sun fires martial arts training would
make him more of a match for almost any
of the x-men with the exception of
Wolverine himself as a result the best
means of defeating and killing Sun Fire
comes in the form of ice man whose
omega-level powers would slow down the
molecular movement of Sun fires plasma
based energies stripping in most powers
or at least reducing them to the point
that he could easily be counter by any
number of units picking up with
Thunderbird despite his imposing size
John proud Stark is relatively easy to
kill if we ignore his death by explosion
uncanny x-men number 95 Thunderbirds
powers are relatively mundane gifted
with superhuman strength speed
durability stamina and oversized lungs
allowing for enhanced respiratory system
which contributed to his enormous size
despite these feats Thunderbirds bark is
worse than his bite capable of lifting
no more than two tons
John proud star super-strength is on the
weaker end of Marvel strong guys as a
result the best means of defeating and
killing Thunderbird comes in the form of
rogue who could not only absorb the
powers of Thunderbird but whose physical
strength is more than enough for John
proud star quite literally tearing him
apart piece by piece
finally and moving on a dabbler as a
mutant with the power to create various
forms of light Alice and Blair can use
these lights for a variety of effects
including the creation of lasers and
mission a proton blasts illuminations
strobes Holograms rocket bursts and
shields in addition to being immune to
the effects of our own powers and
convincing Faust into thinking that
she's cool in addition to this because
of her training as part of the x-men
team while not the most capable of
martial artists she does
have the benefit of enhanced agility
allowing her to run circles around the
average mutant furthermore Dazzler short
time as a Herald of Galactus granted her
use of the power cosmic bestowing her
with cosmic awareness and with it a
greater understanding of her own powers
and the peak of what she could achieve
however Dazzler is not without her
weaknesses despite being able to use
light for a multitude of effects these
abilities are achieved through Dazzlers
absorption and amplification of sound
energy while their powers are best
suited within the biospheres of planets
owing to sound bouncing off the
atmosphere despite the thin presence of
sound in space Dazzler is still able to
control and manipulate what little sound
exists to this end the best person
suited to defeat and kill Dazzler comes
in the form of ruckus owing to his
ability to absorb and channel sound back
at others because these powers are
active instead of passive ruckus must
focus his concentration meaning if he
were to absorb all the sounds in
Dazzlers immediate vicinity she would be
left completely powerless after which
she could be killed by any number of
conventional means with that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end and I'm kind of curious if there is
any mutants x-men or otherwise that I
have not made an exam yur protocols
video on so far post them down the
description and I'll make sure they get
added to the list of characters that I
have coming in future videos and that
we'll catch you all later peace